loosing all the time I can't help it but
I do want to I do want to say something
to you I brought you a gift
Oh because there is only a few people
that I can read if things to and the
reason is is because we share something
we sure actually many things in common
but I would like for you to go ahead and
open this up now oh my god - okay I'm
being honest with you I think that's
anyway go ahead and you'll see why no I
was literally when I sent the video memo
today I was like from Casey to Casey I
thought it was so clever you put them on
your shoe and just say you know Katie
Couric got the other one oh there we go
they actually know a lot of people with
our initials really it's weird what in
the world like a gremlin got out
kookaburra
I can't say when I can feel it I
actually practiced doing him ok wait can
you harmonize with that deep if we
played it could you harmonize with the
kookaburra okay Rob yeah Mindy can you
bring the bird out
[Applause]
all right okay he might not make a sound
now Moe won't but hey can we play it
we're gonna try this in the sit okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
well thank you so much cooker right
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
here's actually my favorite thing about
you right now
you're doing death becomes her on
Broadway is that what's happening yes
are you playing Meryl I'm playing Meryl
Streep I know
[Applause]
for you first of all they came to me and
they said we want to do that that
becomes her and I think I love the movie
I'm which part and they said the Meryl
Streep part and I said does that mean I
get to have my head chopped off I love
you I never turn around because for
those of you don't know it's two women
who are trying to stay young and they do
whatever it takes in that drink this
point potion that makes them stay young
but they they have other things that
fall off I'm excited you have to call I
am a hundred percent gonna fly across
country because I had this person on
this show I love dr. pimple popper I
love her doctors handedly
Sandra Lee who I feel that she's
changing the world because she's giving
people opportunities that might not be
able to afford to go like this one lady
and I'm not making fun but she did have
a major like hump on the back and they
and they're like what is it and she took
it out and it looked like a chicken
cutlet
I actually got hungry I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this